okay now here's where it gets kind of it
starts to get cool
uh and and less technical
i want to go back to project management
and the way that of systems get designed
right and we remember we learned this
cycle of how people would design a
system and
the principles that they use as they
design it so qbe is a kind of system
yeah so i want to think about well okay
what kinds of uh goals and priorities
and principles
did this um this zluf guy uh
this guy what was he thinking what was
he trying to get at
what guiding principles did he have as
he designed qbe and i've got two that
correspond to these two goals that he
had in development okay
so number one remember he wanted to make
it easier
right so the name that we attached to
that that kind of design principle
is it's got two names you can call it
either a user-centered approach
okay sorry i ran out of space or you can
call it
end user development
okay so the the idea here is remember
that the um
the system development life cycle right
it looks something like this
you've got all the different stages
around the edges and then you've got
users here in the middle
okay so uh all the way through when
you're going through each stage if you
remember
okay there's going to be feedback going
back and forth between the users and the
designers the developers yeah
now is the important thing to get maybe
you think well that's obvious
of course you should uh plan and design
and develop with the users in mind and
constantly
um talking to them okay and always
having them as your goal
but that's not always been the case okay
and many systems are still designed
today
without regard to users okay or you know
they're not the primary driving force
what else might you think of what other
kinds of
priorities might you have if you're not
developing mainly for users
who else are you or what else are you
developing for
okay right so instead of the people who
are you know at the end who are going to
benefit it might be the people who are
actually using it in the case of qbe
and sql they actually tend to be the
same people okay end users and
participants they kind of overlap
sometimes
right let me give an example of
something else
a system that's not very well designed
for users
okay but it's very good at what it does
can you think about
um remember under project management i
said there was this triangle
okay do you remember the try the project
triangle and there were three different
things
different quantities i was trying to
balance out um do you remember what they
were what are your three quantities
time okay oh let's get time
i think i heard money what was the other
one
scope good okay
now more so with time and with money
not so much with scope but can you see
that as you're developing a project
right you might prioritize getting the
project done on time
right or minimizing the you know the
actual cost that you spend
rather than having a system that's best
designed for users
okay i'll give you a classic example
that i just heard uh recently on the
news
the northwest rail link okay let's see
if we can um not to be confused with
north west the child of
kim kardashian look see that anyway
sorry i don't know if you are pleased
okay now let's see here yeah good
i don't know if you've um been following
the news i guess i guess
i am because i live in the northwest um
they've recently signed a deal with
these contractors to actually get it
started
building and you know northwest rarely
people are happy and excited
but but this big but right um when they
tunnel through because it's all gonna go
underground right because there used to
be land um
owned by the new south wales government
to put the rail link on um you know on
the on
land okay above land background uh but
the
i think the um the bobcar government
sold it
thank you bob carr anyway therefore
because that land is no longer by the
government they've got to go
underground okay but as you can imagine
digging tunnels is super super expensive
and difficult right
so as a compromise and in order to
reduce the amount of
cost right what they've done is they
said look the tunnels
we're not going to make them the full
height and width
as all the rest of the tunnels in the
new south wales rail network
okay they've made it a bit smaller now
you're like well
why would you do that number one to make
it cheaper right number two
make it faster but what do you think is
the disadvantage
of having it smaller than the rest of
the net rail network
okay you can't fit not quite not about
as many trains
but you can't fit the same trains okay
because i don't know about you uh if you
if you travel on trains regularly
but you might have noticed sort of you
know when you get in
okay you're walking in and then you can
go up or you can go down
right and then there's you know seats up
here seats up here and windows and that
kind of thing right
so these are double decker trains yes
the northwest rail link would cut off
the trains about here
right it's not tall enough or wide
enough to fit these kinds of trains
right so what you've got is trains that
are only going to be single level
and they will just operate on the west
road link around and around and around
and around okay and then
when if you want to go to if i wanted to
go say to the city i have to catch a
train at my local station
and then i have to change once my train
arrives at a normal
station and i get on a big train and
then that'll take me to the city
okay so can you see here that that kind
of development approach
sort of prioritize these two over these
guys
why is this a bad idea for users
why is this so detrimental to users any
ideas
uh how do you well why how do you know
okay sure so um it's going to mean
there's more uh
everyone's cramped in okay because
there's just less space available what
else yeah
ah bingo right as a user experience
right
i now have to use two services not one
right
because i can't just get on this it'll
take me all the way to the city i've got
to change
right and that's a user experience um
issue right
all right now let's start talking about
trains and let's go back to
databases okay sql
it works really well it does its job
very efficiently okay
but it's hard for users to get at so
that's why
this user-centred approach this end-user
principle towards development says look
let's think about the people who are
going to be doing the search
right and how can we make it easier for
them rather than more efficient
for the software okay
all right that's the first design
principle
the second design principle it's a bit
tricky has to do with this one right it
allows users to use
this database language without
understanding it
what we call that is abstraction
abstraction okay abstraction's a bit a
tricky word
i'm not going to because it has so many
different meanings
i'm not going to go into heaps of detail
but all that means in this context is
it allows you to use something while
hiding the details of that thing
from you okay let's say that again
abstraction
is about allowing users people
to use something but hiding the details
from you
okay so for instance um
let's go back to a um you know a
transport metaphor
okay in a car in a car if i want to go
faster
in my car i only have to do one thing i
just get my right foot
and i put it on the accelerator pedal
okay and if i want to go faster i push
further
but i don't want to go as fast i just
push a little bit okay now that's what
we call abstraction
right because actually what the engine's
doing
when i press on the pedal is very very
complicated it's got to
inject fuel and then pistons are going
to do things and then there's like all
these controlled explosions and
combustion inside the engine
which are making the the which drive the
axle which is attached to the wheels and
so on and so forth okay
no no i'm not interested in all those
details right all i want is
go faster okay so what that is
again is abstraction right all these
technical
processes are all still occurring but
they're all hidden from me
all i see is the pedal right does that
make sense
now in just the same way when you go
through
and conduct this search okay there is
actually
a kind of sql query behind this which is
still going to happen it's the engine
the pistons the combustion
but it's all hidden from it all i see is
the pedal right
i just want this right i don't have to
deal with
what exact language it's written in okay
so that's really good for me as a user
these
two principles they kind of feed off
each other
okay a user-centered approach and
abstraction
okay really important keyword